Shane Stanley, Filmmaker/Author/Instructor: I’m
a firm believer that if you're not making noise
with your work and you gotta call agents and
people to represent you then your work is not…
Film Courage: What's your advice
to people on getting representation
whether it's for film, screenwriting, acting?
Shane: Well I think that having representation and
how it comes to you and the need for it is they're
separate. You have to keep them separate. I think
if you're an actor you need it. It's an agent's
job to go through the breakdowns and submit you
for roles to get you taped auditions or in the
room. I mean an actor can't act without people
knowing they exist. I think that cinematographers
that's very important too. I think agents can be
very beneficial to a cinematographer's career.
By and large agents sit around wait for the phone
to ring. I mean let's call it like it is, the days
of agents reading scripts taking 20 or 30 home a
weekend and discovering new property and calling
an actor and saying I just read something you've
got to read. Let's call the producers and tell
them you want to do this, a lot of agents wait for
the phone to ring and I think that when writers,
directors and filmmakers ask about getting
representation I’m a firm believer that you're
either chasing it or it's chasing you and I talk
about this a lot in the book [Shane’s book - WHAT
YOU DON’T LEARN IN FILM SCHOOL: A Complete Guide
To (Independent) Filmmaking] a big chunk of it
about representation and being a filmmaker and I’m
a firm believer that if you're not making noise
with your work and you’ve got to call agents
and people to represent you, then your work is
not going to be something that they're going to
have a real easy time getting behind and selling
and I know that's very harsh to say. Look
I’ve been through 100 agents and managers
and I’ve never gotten a job from one not one
and I've been with some big agencies and big
managers and maybe it's my fault maybe I'm
just horrible and unsellable but I get asked
a lot from from young writers who may have had
a short film made or producers who are trying to
sell sell what they're doing to a bigger scale and
things today especially with the changes in our
industry in the last few years agencies that are
respectable and real they they're kind of signing
people by committee now it's not hip pocketing
the days of an agent taking somebody kind of
off the grid in their back pocket and trying to
do something with that is is really frowned upon
and is something that's really not done as much
anymore if at all so when you go in with a with
a res e and a body of work that you might have
and try to get representation you you have to
they're going check with everybody from the
janitor to the parking attendant to make sure
if they should sign you or not it's it's not just
somebody falling in love with you and unless it's
somebody who runs a boutique on their own that
they are the judge jury and executioner but
I have found that when when you seek out
representation and you have to kind of do a
tap dance to get them to want to get behind your
work and your abilities I always say let's see
where that that relationship is in six months they
usually don't bear much fruit and and that's it's
unfortunate it's hard to get representation as a
writer as a producer as a director in this town
that said it is not hard to create original
content that if it's good enough can get the
attention of a respectable agent or a manager
again we we have endless resources for so cheap
as filmmakers even even student filmmakers
you can get a dslr camera you can get actors
and again don't hire your cousin
and your mother to be in them go to
acting schools and call the people that run
these acting schools and say I'm making a short
I'm doing a spec commercial give me some
good talent there are people out there
that actually know how to act that you
can get and put stuff together if you're
hurdle is well I can't get anything done because
I can't get any money or I can't get anything
done because nobody's behind me then you have
to create the content and if you don't have the
content created how are people going to know if
you're worthy of being represented or not I'm not
trying to discourage anybody from trying to
get representation and I'm sure there are
those wonderful relationships where the artist has
banged down the door enough times and the agent
finally said okay I'll rep you and it's gone
well there are those exceptions but by and large
the majority of the time first-time writers
and I say first-time writers and I finished
a screenplay or I have a book on amazon where's
my agent it doesn't work that way and if it does
let's see how that went after six months
I just don't think that when you have to
try to convince somebody to represent you
that that that's that's a passion I think
when a true agent or manager gets behind somebody
I think they have to be passionate about them
I think they have to be they're they're working
for the artist and they have they only get paid
on commission and who are they going to spend
their days banging down the doors for and if
if you're an actor I really believe you need
an agent but talking about the filmmaker side
it's tough to get representation and and I often
tell filmmakers don't don't spin your wheels and
burn your calories trying to get an agent
just the amount of time you're trying to
burn the phones to find an agent you should
be shooting something that's going to make
an agent say holy moly I saw this on Youtube I
saw this on Vimeo I saw this at a film festival
or at least if you are going to bang on
those doors you should have three or four
short films or something I know a very successful
commercial director who's who's been at the top
of the game for many years and I asked him once I
said how did you get in the game you didn't come
from film school you didn't have parents that
could he said hey man I got a camera I got I
got friends who could act I got guys who can hold
sound and I knew how to direct I knew how to cut
and I went out and I started doing spec
commercials like he did Doritos, Coca-Cola,
Pepsi he would just grab product and do these
incredible how like Doritos would have these
contests where your own campaign and maybe we'll
use it he would just do that for everything he
would do cars like if his mom got a new BMW
mom let me make a car commercial for BMW
and this guy had like 20 or 30 commercials and
they all looked like really big commercials and
he was able to go in and say this is what I can
do this is who you're representing keep in mind
when you go to an agent they need content to sell
you because they're going to make phone calls
or emails on your behalf and the decision makers
are going to say great let me see their work and
if you don't have work the agent's job you're kind
of you're kind of kneecapping the agent going in
because they're going to come to you and say you
got to get me content and it's it can't be looked
at as a chicken or egg type thing that's an excuse
the filmmaker the artist has to get out there
and and create the content now if you're a writer
I'm a firm believer that you may you may excel
or be passionate about writing one thing
I think it's important if you're unknown
to really stretch and try to try to get three or
four spec scripts done in different genres because
there are companies that are just making thrillers
that may read your script that an agent can take
to somebody like Mar Vista and say hey you're
doing a bunch of stuff for a lifetime look at this
if the agent can get it in the room it'll get
a look but there's also companies that only
do horror there's companies like Hallmark
that only do romantic comedies or whatever
those things are called and if you're a writer
that's looking to get representation the agent
is going to want and need as much ammunition
as possible you have to make their job easy
and if you give them three or four different a
pallet of different things they're going to be
able to circulate three or four different scripts
maybe 15 or 20 different companies think about
what the odds just come of you not only getting
somebody in your corner to represent you but
getting seen and getting a reputation a wonderful
woman I met a year and a half ago at a webinar
right when kovitz started brilliant writer she
writes these beautiful romantic little films
that are just Hallmark and she got a script read
and she got a green light and she got the film
produced and now she's a working writer and she we
talked about it and she was like oh my goodness I
got genres in everything this woman was pushing
a genre but when it came time to getting looked
at and getting representation she had a whole
plethora of stuff to give to them and say look
I can write anything and that's what she's doing
now and and you have to I think too many of us sit
around and wait for the phone to ring or the door
to get knocked on or somebody to know somebody you
have to be so proactive on on creating content to
get people excited about what you do I go back to
we talk about films like napoleon dynamite started
as a short saw was a short sling blade was a short
there's there's so many of those films even
whiplash was a short they obviously did
something right to get the attention to get these
things made into major motion pictures that hasn't
changed people forget that those four great films
started from beginnings I mean Napoleon Dynamite
the short was in black and white for crying out
loud I mean it's horrible but it was great but
it was it was so bad it was good right but
that's how we have to think as filmmakers
James Wan did it brilliantly with his short for
saw I mean I encourage everybody go on youtube
find these films they're all there they're all
there you can find these shorts and you will see
where Billy Bob Thornton got Sling Blade from you
will see where Napoleon Dynamite and Whiplash all
came from because they're all they're all
there and they all started because somebody
said screw it I'm going do it. and that's
that's what I tell people they need to do
so maybe we are too much in this mindset of like I
need to have my people do it oh wait I don't have
people I need to get people I need to get people
I I'm i'm not successful until I have people
and we're not willing to say wait a minute I'm not
there yet a lot of people have a hard time saying
I'm not there yet and that's a really good point
we all have to be able to say we're not there yet
and truly identify and accept when we're not and
get over that next. I mean I deal with a lot of
actors that when we do workshops and do acting
class work and it's awesome like I need a team
you need a team for what you've had an agent for
two years you go out on 15 auditions a week you're
not booking you need to better the craft you ever
think maybe you're just not good in a room do
you ever think maybe you need to study better and
look at the reel and half the time they're not off
book and they've had the work for three days and
you're reading one scene you're not off book yet
these are the kind of things that that really will
impact an actor from getting past an audition and
it's it's very hard for artists we are so myopic
we are so self-centered anyway it's in our nature
we we're very selfish people but when it comes
to getting to the next level it's very very rare
that somebody can look and say it's me I need to
get off my behind and create content I need to
get into acting class two or three nights a
week I need to go take a class in basic lighting
if I really want to be a cinematographer
or a director I need to understand lenses
I need to I tell everybody who wants to write
produce direct and and get in the edit bay
that's where you're going to learn it more than
anything because you're going to see you're going
to fix other people's mistakes you're going to
you're going to learn what ends up on a cutting
room floor you're going to realize the amount of
time you waste on a set and what that'll do is
it'll better you when you make your short films
and it'll better you when when writing scripts
I mean it's amazing how many writers have never
been in the edit bay that's the most important
place there are three scripts there's the one you
write the one that's shot and the one that's cut
and if you can if you can bridge the gap between
the one that's written and the one that's released
boy it's a helpful tool and I know writers are
going to bash me for saying that but get your
button to write any edit bay and realize what what
you write and how it affects production costs and
putting certain amount of characters in a certain
scene and you got to remember you got to cover all
that get multiple takes on every actor and
what that does production is a lot of good
we talk about this in other another webinars
I've done and the writer needs to understand
a production mindset because there are some
great scripts out there that that don't get read
past 20 or 30 pages and it's because they don't
understand it from a produceral view where you
really have to think about when you write a
script you can say well it shouldn't be that
expensive it just takes place in a flat in New
York and well okay how many people are in it how
many different locations what is your logistics
here and you have to think of who you're going
after you realistically to produce it and does
it fit in what they're doing it's about finding
that connection with a producer with your written
word but also kind of going back to what you said
making an agent's job easier if you have an agent
that isn't WME or CAA level that's not going to
kick down doors and get you to every studio
you got to realize the level of the agent or
manager you're working with and where they have
the ability to get you now if you are able to
work with somebody and somebody is showing
interest in working with you I think it's
very important you have that talk early on is
what is your ability to get me through the door
what are the studios networks production shingles
whatever they call them where can you get my stuff
read so that artist that writer can understand
okay this manager can only get me in a hallmark
so they need to start thinking about okay let
me get this stuff together for you that's going
to give you the path of least resistance
start getting my my stuff to you that you
can go to hallmark with or is it lifetime let
me get you some thrillers let me get you some
husband came out of jail wants to see his
kid scripts let me give you some of those and
and that's that's important it's not just about
being a good writer it's about finding a match
and finding out who your potential representatives
have the ability or juice to get to so the work
that you submit to them it resonates with the
people that it's ultimately going to get read by
because if you have a great script and the
people that are reading it have no business
making a film like that or no interest in making a
story like that it doesn't matter it's just wasted
time what if someone says though that I'm not a
DIY person like that I want my I'm kind of grew
up with staff and different things so I need I
need to have my people do this well if you've
grown up with staff you should be able to write
checks so write check and go make a movie I mean
that's fine I mean I'm sorry but yeah I think
you're in the wrong business I mean it's it's
very rare that somebody can sit in a basement
and just crank out scripts and the day is
going come or that script is read by the right
agent or the right assistant to an actor and
I mean there's always the lottery I mean people
win the lottery that's true I think the odds are
about the same but I think you need to if you're
not DIY and you need people and you need a staff
then what I think you need to do is find other
people that are needing a staff but one of them
has a camera and one of them is an actor and one
of them may be an editor and work together we
talked earlier about people working together and
building something special and building building a
team everybody having a common goal to get to the
next level and that's what I tell a lot of writers
I said the cool thing about being a writer is
you don't need anybody to tell you to go to work
you you really have the only job in this industry
that you you may not get paid yet or at all
but nobody can tell you you can't work right now
you have the ability to roll out of bed turn on
a light at two in the morning and write and that's
a beautiful thing because an actor is not going to
be able to get in front of a camera and tap dance
unless there's a script director doesn't have
anything to direct unless there's a script there's
nothing to produce without a script the writers
are essential I mean it's so important it's an
incredible position to be in if you're not able to
be a writer producer director editor or filmmaker
and all your focus is on writing then you need to
get out more and you need to find people of like
mind that have those skill sets or the materials
to get your products seen it's just it's not going
to sitting in a pdf on an external hard drive or
somewhere on your computer is not going
to get it made it's about getting it with
people and I'm very big a lot of people like
to talk about pitch decks and proof of concept
some of the most impressive things I've seen
are when people go out and shoot a scene or
two or three to me that's a real pitch deck
that's a proof of concept I don't want to see
papers and comps and actors you're never going
to acquire on your proof of your pitch deck I
want to see you go out and shoot a scene for
your film with comparable qualified people
and people that are passionate about
it and I think some of those true
pocs [proof of concept] that I've seen they
knock me out of my seat I can't believe what
people are putting together these days and I
mean for nothing no money there's no excuse.
Question
For The Viewers:
How essential are agents and managers
to someone starting their careers?